let's talk about Amy Goodman Amy Goodman
from democracy now there's really some
great news coming out from her case if
you weren't aware Amy Goodman was on the
scene of the North Dakota access
pipeline protests by the star the Sioux
tribes and she actually was the one who
brought national attention to what was
going on back in September in September
third she was there reporting and
getting coverage and exposing it to the
world and she got coverage of private
contractors essentially a private
security / mercenaries using attack dogs
on protesters and I have some images
here if you look at them you can see the
image of the dog with blood dripping
from its mouth it you know the dogs were
sent to attack the protesters it was it
was a horrible scene and Amy Goodman's
reporting kind of catapulted night kind
of absolutely catapulted this to the
national stage that was September third
September eighth a warrant was issued
for her arrest or criminal trespassing
at the after about a few weeks of this
story being out in the public's eye this
prosecuting attorney dropped the charge
from criminal trespassing because he did
not have enough evidence to actually
charge with that and instead went with a
charge of inciting riots so Amy Goodman
had to go to North Dakota on yesterday
and thankfully the judge said that there
was not enough evidence to actually
charge her with it the state's attorney
involved his name was lat Erica's
Erickson he dropped the charge from
criminal trespass to inciting riots and
then the the judge himself actually said
no there's not enough evidence here's
the thing and she actually said it best
let me quote her she said quote by
filing the charges in the first place
the state's attorney was attempting to
stop journalism and in many ways Pat
this is an example of a retribution of
retribution of the police and the
private contractors the companies
actually being angry with her for this
coverage because
she exposed something on the national
level that was really only on social
media and they pressed charges against
her I mean when's the last time you
actually have heard of journalists being
charged with trespassing when they're
there to cover a story I really don't
hear that too often yeah it's just the
way for them to quiet her in the future
that's how you know that you're doing
good journalism is when you're kind of
breaking the boundaries and pushing the
limits of what you can do and it seems
like they were just trying to get back
at her and prevent her from doing it
again yeah and actually glad you
mentioned that it was actually Ferguson
was the last time I remember a
journalist being charged with criminal
trespass for covering a story if you
remember the Ferguson protests some
years ago there are several reporters
who were arrested and charged for the
same type of thing and it speaks to the
need for the system and the powers that
be to keep certain situations quiet
thankfully Amy Goodman the charges have
been dropped yeah I'm sure was a major
inconvenience for her life personally
but if anyone was up to the task of
challenging this type of of this type of
violation the violation of the First
Amendment it was Amy Goodman from
democracy now so congratulations Amy we
really love your work and continue to
keep doing that work we'll be back after
this break and we'll be back a little
bit more of the david pakman show with
your special guest host benjamin dixon